I don't know if I can go out this  Halloween I'm really trying to stick to  this health thing  and go outside I cannot take you serious  right now  you're telling me you don't know I'm  trying to stick to this health thing you  have a processed meat head I'm just a  guy trying to cut the mustard right I  gotcha uh and it's been a real dog  trying to stop oh my God I got no beef  ketchup going I know I got no beef would  you not going but catch up I know and  look let us let us let us talk about all  these things why would anything in my  life be a decent case scenario it's got  to be the worst case scenario can you  cook that whole thing of him in the hot  dog head and just use that for when we  need it please please